welcome to
introduction to machine learning this
lecture is a
an example and the idea is that we will
go through a very simple
example using all the topics that we've
discussed so far
and take a little bit of a look at the
sort of results one can
expect and also the
code that's necessary to get it to work
so this is a a data set that comes from
kaggle kaggle is a google owned company
that
organizes machine learning competitions
you can go to kaggle
and download data
for a range of different uh
domains in this case this is uh house
prices kaggle also keeps
data sets in escrow so that one can
compare
the results of your own machine learning
algorithm
against a
validation set which you've not seen
before and other people haven't seen
before
and it also keeps track of other
people's performance on particular data
sets
so it's a worthwhile place to go to get
experience with
trying machine learning a variety of
domains
this is a data set that consists
of prices and features
for 1456
homes in ames iowa and those were
homes that were sold between 2006 and
and
here our goal is going to be to try to
use
the features of the houses in order to
predict the price and we're going to
focus on predicting the log of the price
because the prices relative price
is uh much more important than absolute
price
and house prices typically vary over a
significant range
so our performance metric is going to be
the rms error
on the test set of the log of the house
price
now in particular if you have a an rms
error of
say 0.1 then it means that you can
predict house prices within a factor of
e to the point one
which is about ten and a half percent
here's the sort of thing one sees in
this data here we have a plot of the
target variable which is the log of the
price
against one of the independent variables
the living area of the house in this
case
and you can see well first of all
there's uh
quite a lot of variation just knowing
the living area doesn't narrow down the
price very much
here we've got house prices varying
between
e to the 10 and a half and e to the
13 e to the 14.
which is must be less than
100 000 to more than 500 000
and uh so we're seeing quite a quite a
variation here
now the data set actually contains some
80 features
we're going to use maybe
the first 20 features
and uh focus on
uh on those so for our embedding
uh for embedding the target variable
we're going to let v be the price and y
be the log of v it's the log of the
price
and then for the independent variables x
we're going to
embed them as follows we have some of
those
fields of a house record are numerical
and we those we can just embed unchanged
so in particular we have the year the
house was built
the area of the living space the area of
the first floor the area of the second
floor
the area of the garage the area of the
wooden deck
the area of the basement the year of the
last remodel and the area of the lot
so all of the areas are in square feet
they're just numbers
and the years are simply years they're
just integers
and we will just embed those as numbers
as they are
there are also ordinal fields in our
features
and we will embed those as integers so
we have a number of bedrooms
number of kitchens number of fireplaces
number of half bathrooms number of
rooms condition condition is a number
that's scored between 1 and 10 that's
assigned by
an expert
presumably an appraiser or a realtor
we have the quality of the materials and
the finish again assigned by an expert
but it's a score of between one and ten
and the number of cars that the garage
can hold
so these are all small integers
typically between
zero and ten and we just embed them as
as they are
the kitchen quality is
a field which is stored on a leica scale
the kitchen is rated excellent good
typical
fair or poor although i don't think
there are actually any
entries in the data set that we see for
poor rating
and this is encoded as an integer
between one and five
after we embed it
the building type is a categorical
field this is embedded one hot
and so it's embedded as a five
dimensional
vector one of the canonical unit vectors
with a one in one position and zero and
all the other positions
the five different categories are single
family
townhouse end unit two family conversion
townhouse inside unit and duplex
there's also a neighborhood field there
are 25
different neighborhoods so it's a
categorical data
field and this is also one hot embedded
as a result we have looking back at our
fields here we have 17
numerical fields
and we have
the kitchen quality which is 18 and
then we have 30
components which are one hot so
the total dimension of our
x data variable
is 48 and we're going to add one more
which will be the constant
now when we do the standardization and
the data splitting we do this in a
particular way
so we split the data randomly 80 20 80
for training and 20 for test
and that gives us an x zero training set
and a corresponding y train and an x
zero test set and a corresponding
y-test now the way we do standardization
is we use the training set to compute
the means
and the standard deviations of each of
the features
so that means we'll get 48 numbers
corresponding to the means each column
of x0 train
and 48 numbers correspond to the
standard deviations
of each column of x03
and now we can use the means and
standard deviations to standardize
x zero train simply by
subtracting off the means and dividing
by the standard deviations
and we use the same means and standard
deviations to standardize
the test set now in particular here we
don't want to
use the test set to compute the means
and the standard deviations
because that would be including
information from our test set into our
predictor there's also a particular
caveat that you should be aware of and
that is because
many of our variables are categorical
it often happens that particular columns
of x train are actually all zeros
there's no
data record for example that corresponds
to a house in a particular neighborhood
and that will give you a standard
deviation of zero and so if you try to
apply the straightforward
standardization uh then of course that
will fail because we'll be trying to
divide by zero but that's very simple
all we do is we simply
include that as a column of zeros in the
data set
so after we've standardized both the
training and the test set using this
these means and standard deviations we
can then apply
append a constant feature to both of
them
and then we'll have x train and x test
and x train will be 1165 by 49
the next test will be 291 by 49.
so now we're going to do ridge
regression so we're going to
use the remember the rms
log price as our performance metric
and so our loss will be the quadratic
loss we'll be minimizing the media
empirical mean square
error in the log of price
and
regularization will use bridge
regression so we will use the quadratic
regular visor
so remember how we do regularized
empirical risk minimization
we choose a range of lambda values
logarithmically spaced here we choose
them between 10 to the minus 3 and 10 to
the 3.
and for each one of those lambdas we
solve the regularized empirical risk
minimization problem to find a theta
we choose a theta we find the theta that
minimizes
this quadratic function of the vector
theta
notice that we've used a capital y here
even though
capital y here is actually just a vector
not a
matrix because m is one we've only got a
single target
variable
and notice also that we're not
regularizing the constant term
in theta
once we've got these
theta values i think we have 50
different
lambda values and so we get 50
corresponding theta values
then uh
for each one of those theta values we
can compute
the training error simply by computing
the
rms of x train times theta minus y train
that's just a vector
so uh we take uh
the one on n times the sum of the
squares of that vector
and then square root that quantity and
similarly the test error
x test theta minus y test
and for this data set this is what we
see
here on the left we have
two curves plotted against theta we have
the
empirical risk of the different thetas
so at any given lambda value we have a
corresponding theta
we have a corresponding test error and a
corresponding train error
we can see that at all thetas the test
error is a lit does a little bit worse
than the uh training
and in fact regularization
appears to offer no benefits here
the the data is sufficiently we have a
sufficiently large amount of data
compared to the
number of features that we have that
there's no danger of overfitting and
as a result the regularization does
little for us
um the minimum rms
error is about point one two
which corresponds to about a 13 error in
house price
over here on the right we have the plot
of
theta versus lambda the regularization
path
we can see that even with
lambda about
0.1 we're starting to see
some shrinkage the components of theta
are getting smaller
without any loss in performance so a
reasonable choice of lambda
would be something of that order
somewhere between
0.1 and 1.
here we have the test data and each
point on this plot
shows two values the
true price y this is of course the true
log price and the
predicted log price y-hat
and ideally we would expect we would
want to have all points
on the diagonal indicating that we've
predicted perfectly
and the points are clustered reasonably
well
about diagonal we're not doing badly
we have some outliers
here and here where we are
vastly overestimating the price
and also here
but otherwise we're doing okay and
perhaps one thing one might do after
making these kind of predictions is to
go back and look at those data
records and figure out why
the true price for those is so much less
than the predicted price
we can also look at the the theta the
entries of theta tell us something about
the importance of the different features
and we can see that
this one this one this one and this one
are important features as
is this one this one and this one those
are the theater
entries that have the largest magnitudes
they correspond to
these seven features
four of those are about the size of the
house
area of living space area first floor
area of second floor area of basement
very reasonable things that would drive
the price of a house
one of them is the year in which it was
built so how new is the house
and the other two are the experts
assessments of the condition and quality
and so it's quite reasonable to see that
these things show up as the most
important determinants
of the price of a house
you can also notice that there are
interesting
points here the last
25 features
in x are one hot encoding
of the neighborhood and
if we look for example at this point and
this point
there's a this one's about .02 and this
one's about minus
0.02
and that means that
if i move from this neighborhood
over here to this neighborhood over here
well then this first component here
the 31st 32nd
33rd component of x
switches from a 1 to a 0 and the 30th
component of x which is from a 0 to 1
and so my contribution of theta
transpose
times x from those two components
changes
from minus 0.02 to plus
0.02 which means that the
house price changed by about four
percent
so just by moving from one neighborhood
to another
we can see that much change in house
price
and this these last
few entries of theta tell us which are
the desirable neighborhoods and which
are the undesirable neighborhoods
okay let's take a look at the code
um first of all we can just run it and
see uh
that it does what we think it should do
uh let's include
the file is called house.jl
and the main
function here is what we're going to run
and that should do the computation
and produce
the plots every time you run it it will
produce slightly different plots because
remember the
test and train split is chosen randomly
we can see here this is just the
raw data file this is another
piece of raw data
here we can see i think these features
we can see
what we've plotted here uh
no so this code will be available
on the website there are two files in
particular house.jl
which does all the computation and then
there's another file
called houseplots.jl
and houseplots.jl does the plotting
that requires
pipelot or you'll have to modify it to
use whatever plotting package
you are using uh so here we're plotting
two things we're
plotting the lot area and the living
area
and so versus price and so here are two
features this is
a living area and this is lot area and
we can see that there's quite a few
really extremely large houses
which shift which are really outliers in
our data set
and so if we were to go through and uh
remove those
or adjust for those in some way we might
find
ourselves doing slightly better in our
fits
one can open the data file
in a spreadsheet and one can see
the 1500 or so different
records in the corresponding 80 or so
different
fields
now if we look at the plots that were
generated this is our regularization
path
that's um
i don't need the plotting file anymore
this is our test and train errors as a
function of
lambda
and what's back there is our prediction
versus true value
let's take a look at how this works
so i have two windows on the screen one
is my julia terminal
and the other is my editor containing
the julia code
this studio code is about 150 lines long
to do everything that we did today
the first thing it does is it loads the
data
we can just take that and paste it into
here
now that gives us two things it gives us
d
which is a matrix which is an array of
strings
1456 rows by 81
columns the 81 different fields i guess
the first field there is simply identify
an identifier so there's really 80
different um
fields and every entry in this matrix is
a string and that's loaded by
a function at the top of this file
called
load data which doesn't do anything very
interesting it just calls the csv
library
to load it it does one thing here which
is it removes
what turns out to be a couple of
outliers i think there are four of them
which have a living area
greater than 4 000 square feet and those
are
uh really quite extraordinary
uh houses in this data set so we remove
those
and then it just returns for us the data
d and the header which is a list of the
field
names
now we can take n it's the number of
records we're going to have it's there
now we do two embeddings one is y
so embed y let's take a look at that
what that does this is the function
definition here
it's a one line function definition
some things to notice uh let's uh let's
take a look at this
so get data field simply pulls out
uh that column of the data
so there's the prices
um let's just call that something new
there we go and now string to number
these are all strings just from the way
the csv format is stored
so we can string to number it
let's just call that u1 and now we've
got an array of
floating point numbers now one thing to
notice about this this is a feature of
julia that's worth being aware of is the
dot
notation so uh string to number
will happily take a string
and return you back a number but
actually what u is
is not a string it's a it's an array of
strings or a list of strings
and so by using the dot notation
so if we were to call string to number
on just you
it would say error this you can't
call the function that string to number
calls which is the parse function on an
array but you can
do this and what that does is it of
course causes
string to number to be applied to each
entry
of the array u and it constructs an
array of the results
so if i give it another an array
of strings
it will happily give me back an array
of numbers if i call it with the dot
and so we're just applying string to
number to each of the entries
of that data record
that's what u1 is and then we're
applying the log to each of the entries
of that
to get y and so if i call
embed y d
header it returns me back a vector which
is the log of all the prices
that's what y is
now we can embed x
this is substantially more complicated
because we've got a bunch of different
fields
let's take a look at that first of all
let's see what it does
that returns for us x which is our 1456
by 48 array of
the different fields that we have 20
fields
some of which are encoded as one hot and
so they correspond to more than one
column of this
matrix and all of our data records are
14 56 different houses
now the way this works is that
in the embed x function here this is the
function definition
we can see there's two convenient
functions defined at the top
these are just for convenience what they
do is they're
closures they store the value of d
and header so that whenever i call field
name
inside this function embed x
i don't need to supply d and header
similarly when i call real f name that's
just the same as calling string to
number
dot of get data field
of d header name
so real f here stands for real field
and so what we're doing is we are
we can define these functions in the
julia loop here on the left
and now if i do real if
of year built we can see what it's going
to do it's going to string to number
the data field corresponding to year
built
which is just a list of those numbers
and we can do we do this for each one of
these
and we get simply the list of
the corresponding field numbers
now we can also look at
some of the more complicated ones one
here that's more complicated
is the kitchen quality field
if we look at the kitchen quality field
that's a leica scale the entries in it
are gd for good ta for typical
um excellent and
then maybe out there are others we can
unique
that and see all of the unique entries
in it good
typical excellent or fair
the unliked function
what that does is it maps
these particular strings to
numbers here it is
so unlike hurt sets up a dictionary
which maps
x to five good to four ta to three
fair to two and poor to one and returns
the corresponding number and so if
i apply
on leicard
to that i get a list of numbers
notice the dot again because i'm
applying the unliked function
to each entry of the array separately
and returning back an array of the
results
there's one more little piece of
conversion that goes on and that's the
one hot conversion
if i look at say the field building type
let's look at the smaller of the two
like that again is a list of strings
categories five different possible
categories we can look at what they are
by doing unique
there are the five categories and the
one
hot here one heart does not
work entry wise one hot works on the
entire
list of 1456 strings
and it simply finds the categories which
are here are unique
u so we have u is equal to
that unique of u is going to be the
categories
and then it constructs a matrix which is
each row is a canonical unit vector
which is five dimensional
which is five is the number of
categories so we can see what it does
if we do one hot of u
there's our one hot encoded
building types
here we have h cat which joins
all of these columns together into one
large matrix
and so that if i call embed x i get the
large
matrix
of all of our data
now test train rows and test rows are
just lists of rows which are randomly
selected
split there is 80 20. when we call it
we'll get a new split
let's see what that looks like yeah so
train rows just says well you should use
these particular rows
as your training set and
these particular rows is your test set
and there
that's all of the rows together and
that's a there's a disjoint
now what we do is we split up the feet
the the data set
apply split does the
does the the thing you might expect
let's look at what apply split does
apply split simply splits the
data picks out the corresponding rows
for the train and the test set
let me just run that and now i've got
an x train zero and an x
test zero my
sets of features corresponding to the
training and the test sets and the
corresponding
y's
now the get statistics function gets the
means and the standard deviations of
each column
very simply
so let's look at what that does
so now how many means have i got i've
got 48 means
because x trained zero remember i had 48
columns
and secondly i've got 48 standard
deviations you can see there's quite a
variation
in their means and in their standard
deviations
which is why it's important to
standardize
standardized plus one convenience
function
that goes through
and does the standardization
transformation on each column divides
subtracts the mean and divides by the
standard deviation except in the case
when the standard deviation is zero
which can happen in which case we simply
subtract the mean
and then does one more thing after doing
the standardization
which is that it appends a column of
ones
of course we can't do that before
standardizing because that will just
have its mean subtracted off
so if we do that x train and x test well
that gives us our true x train and x
test from x train 0 and x test 0.
now we're constructing lambdas which is
our list of lambdas no what we're doing
here is dot to the power of
which means again it's a broadcasting
call of the function
call of the function power this time so
it applies
10 to the power of each of the elements
of the range
so we have the range here which is
between
uh -3 and 3 that's a
has a particular data type which has a
colon in it's a range
if you want to see it as a list you can
by doing collect
and then you'll see it as a list now
if i do lambdas to it
then i'll get my list of logarithmically
spaced between ten to the minus three
and ten to the three lambdas
now we do a ridge regression we've seen
that function before
this is applying it one by one to each
of the lambdas
for each lambda in lambdas
call ridge regression to give me which
returns a theta
and make a list of the thetas that's
what this notation means this is called
a list
comprehension if we run
it
there we go we've got a list of thetas
we can look at the size of the theta's
variable
and it's just a 50 dimensional list
theta's
one the first entry is a 49-dimensional
vector the same for all the others the
each one of those is the theta
corresponding to a lambda
now for each one of those we do another
little for loop here another list
comprehension for each
theta we compute x train times theta
which is remember the prediction of y
on the training set elements and we
compute the rms
error over all of the training elements
and the same for the test errors
so now we can do one more thing which is
find the minimum of the test errors
here this tells us that the 16th element
of test errors was the smallest
and the corresponding test error is
0.122
we can also see what the corresponding
theta is by looking at
the corresponding entry of theta we can
see what the corresponding lambda is
there's the corresponding lambda
and we can just work out what those are
right there
and everything else so now it's printing
we print
our results
print the optimal train optimal test
optimal lambda in the optimal feeder
uh and then there's a plotting which
will go through and make the plots that
you saw
it needs all of these data elements to
do that
and this is really how one would do
everything that we've seen so far in the
class to do with regression
we could create more complicated
features for x
we could create for example uh more
one hot features for instead of
our simple real number embedding of our
ordinals
we could create product features and
we could pick out the outliers and
there's a few things we could do
now in fact for this data set none of
those things seems to make a great deal
of difference
which is why we haven't done them now
we'll see other examples where
we can do some of the more fancy things
that involve more fancy embeddings and
more fancy regularizations